[موسيقى]
رغم فشله في حراسه مرمى فريقه الكروي
المفضل ورغم مسيره طويله تخللتها انتكاسات
وخيبات امل وجلسات علاج من الادمان تمكنا
كونان من ان يزيح الاسماء الكبيره من سماء
هوليود وينافسها على منصات الاوسكار
فما قصته
ولد عام
1976 في ايرلندا كان والده وعمه رياضيين
محترفين فظن انه سيصير على ذات الدرب فلعب
في فريق دبل للواعدين كحارس مرمى فيما
كانت والدته مسره على اشراكه في الفنون
المسرحيه
التحق كولين بمدرسه للتمثيل الا انه حصل
على فرصه البدايه قبل ان يكمل دراسته وكان
ذلك عندما اختير لدور في جزء من مسلسل
باليكس سينجل وهو دراما تلفزيونيه لهيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه ومنها انطلق لادوار
ثانويه اخرى في العديد من البرامج
التلفزيونيه والافلام قبل ان يمثل في اول
دور رئيسي له وهو جندي في الدراما
التلفزيونيه تايجر لاند
ثم ظهر كولين بعدها في عدد قليل من
الافلام غير الناجحه تجاريا لكن عام 2003
شكل تحولا في مسيرته حيث حققت ادواره في
فندق وسوات وذريت نجاحات في شباك التذاكر
في عام 2004 قدم فعل دور الاسكندر الاكبر
في فيلم عن سيره الكسندر لاليفر ستون
فرتدى فرول شعرا مستعارا اشقر واحتفظ
بلهجته الايرلنديه وقدم اداء جيدا ومع ذلك
تم انتقاده هو والفيلم فيما لقي اداؤه
التالي بفيلم ذني ورد عام 2005 استحسانا
النقاد رغم انه لم ينجح تجاريا بين الفشل
والنجاح وجد كل نفسه مقحما في متاهه
الادمان على العقاقير الترويحيه ومسكنات
الالم فكان عليه ان يتخذ قرارا جريئا في
حياته عندما دخل طوعا في مركز علاج اعاده
التاهيل وذلك في ديسمبر 2005
كانت تلك المرحله صعبه جدا في حياته لكنها
لم تمنعه من مواصله المسيره فعاد للعمل
وشارك بفيلمي اسك دوداست ومايك الفايز
خلال العام التالي 2006 ونال تقيما جيدا
في شباك التذاكر
[موسيقى]
التحول الحقيقي في مسيره كولين جاء بعد
ظهوره في فيلم اندروج عام 2009 الذي اعتبر
احد افضل افلامه حتى الان وحصل عنه على
اول جائزه جولدن جلوب
لاحقا استمر كولن في الاعمال الناجحه
فتلقى الاشاده لادواره في هاربل باص
سبرايتنايت
وتوتال ريكول
قبل ان يقدم فيلمه الاكثر شهره مؤخرا وهو
ذا بانشيز الذي اهله للفوز بمجموعه جوائز
ابرزها جائزه جولدن جلوب لافضل ممثلا هذا
العام
كما حصل على العديد من الجوائز خلال مسيره
قدم فيها ما لا يقل عن 52 عملا وخاصه في
السنوات الاخيره
اليوم لدى الشاب الصاعد الذي اراد ان يكون
حارس مرمى جمهور عريض من عشاق السينما
وبات يمتلك ثروه تقدر بثمانين مليون دولار
وهو ما منحه شهره تفوق العديده من نجوم
الرياضه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]